there's a story
that daily wire just broke which is
the evidence for an intuition that I
said at the beginning of the Bud Light
story you know the most important story
in the news today the Bud Light put a
transvestite on a can designed initially
for Frat Boys and construction workers
it actually does matter because it tells
you a lot about how corporations work
when that story came out
and
transheiser Bush a b inbev came out and
said oh we know nothing about this this
was just some marketing lady and we the
senior leadership didn't know and but
we're not going to totally apologize for
it but we're going to try to distance
ourselves and but we definitely didn't
know my first reaction was
I don't buy it
it was convenient that they could put
the whole thing on that VP of marketing
Alyssa heinershide I think her name was
because there were some videos of her
that were unflattering making fun of the
Bud Light customer base I said there's
no way it was just this random VP of
marketing
this is a systemic company-wide issue
Bud Light and anti-transhyzer Bush and
ab and Bev broadly are pro-trans and
they're just trying to create a little
bit of distance and put it on this
random lady
but it's not that's why they won't
apologize if if Bud Light really were
opposed to the Dylan Mulvaney of it all
or post a transvestitism and this crazy
social position from the left
then they would have come out and
apologized and they would have fired the
VP of marketing right away they would
have issued a clarifications that we
don't support Mulvaney we don't support
transgenderism they didn't do that
so because it has very little to do with
that VP of marketing and now we've got
the evidence for it
the evidence is
that
Anheuser-Busch is not the good old
American Beer corporation that we're
told that it is Anheuser-Busch is a
Belgian Corporation in 2008
the the Belgian company inbev bought
Anheuser-Busch for for 58 million no I'm
sorry 52 million billion dollars
now
being owned by a Belgian company the
a b inbev family of products is now
beholden to
the more European more left-wing more
pro-un more Pro World economic Forum
kinds of corporate policies and they're
they're expressing that in their own
words a b and Bev admits it wants to
ensure pro-trans diversity quote touches
upon all functions including marketing
now they're going to can this lady
Alyssa heinershine for doing her job a B
inbev has embraced all sorts of woke
initiatives the ESG movement
environmental social governance policies
Dei diversity equity and inclusion all
the rest of it along with a full
endorsement of French genderism a b
inbev will foot the bill it will help to
fund the transgender transition
surgeries for employees who think that
they're the opposite sex
ABN Bev has an official corporate policy
that exalts quote gender identity and
expression and and raises it to the same
level of significance as race and age
it'd be inbev not only indoctrinates all
of their managers and employees in this
nonsense they also require external
suppliers to submit themselves to this
kind of pro-trans woke nonsense
and this isn't anything new the reason
that I I was able to know this before
the specific details came out it's not
because I'm Nostradamus and I took out
my crystal ball maybe that was part of
it but it's because Bud Light has been
signaling its pro-lgbt stance for years
now but Bud Light has put out all sorts
of rainbow materials in recent years
then they put a transvestite on the can
and people push back and and Bud Light
plays Dumb and plays innocent how did
this ever happen but but it gets even
bigger than that people are raving about
genucel skin care Jessica from
Huntsville Alabama says my skin looks so
soft and clear I've seen a reduced
number of fine lines and dark spots I
found a new lifetime product absolutely
love it can you sell skin care uses a
one of a kind proprietary flower base
developed by the founder and pharmacist
who is a great guy by the way it's also
comes along with rare Botanical extracts
and Powerful antioxidants for skin care
results that work guaranteed I said I
would not endorse the product if I could
not try it if I were not impressed by
the product and also fellas I know
sometimes men are a little skeptical of
getting into Cosmetics too much even
slightly more men than women use
genuscal and for good reason geniusell's
most popular package is available to you
today for 70 off 7-0 at genucel.com
knowlesyt Joy millions of happy
customers who've already fallen in love
with the results Plus for a limited time
yet genu sells probiotic extract
moisturizer free with every most popular
package go to genucel.com knowlesyt
genucel.com
knowlesyt so the World Federation of
advertisers is a huge trade group it
includes people like ABN Bev Adidas BP
CVS Goldman Sachs MasterCard McDonald's
Merck Nike Procter Gamble of course the
wokis corporation on Earth Hershey
Disney Unilever Walmart among others
they created
a new entity
and the entity is called garm
garm is the Global Alliance for
responsible media
Libs love acronyms and initialisms and
so garm is a quote cross industry
initiative
so this is an agreement among the
world's largest corporations and
platforms that's crucial
to demonetize what they consider to be
harmful content
what do you think qualifies as harmful
content just true things
so a b and Bev and the big Tech
platforms such as YouTube
Tick Tock they created new standards to
limit the reach of and demonetize
content that it contains quote hate
speech about
you guessed it gender identity
insensitive treatment of debated social
issues and misinformation when did this
policy come out when when did this major
corporate group
start start clamping down on
misinformation
why in their words quote in the wake of
the covid-19 pandemic
so in the wake of what the the Liberals
themselves were calling a great reset
of our economy and Society
the biggest corporations in the world
team up with far-left organizations the
European commission the NAACP and they
create these new standards some of which
are explicitly pro-trans so garm
is so powerful garm garm controls so
much money not just the advertising
budget of Bud Light but lots of other
entities too
that the big Tech platforms YouTube
Facebook Instagram Twitter Tick Tock
Snapchat all of them
are writing pages and pages of reports
about how they will run their platforms
to satisfy the garm standards we have
screenshots of all of this I have a long
Twitter thread on this if you want to go
check it out
and then the little cherry on top of
this liberal Sunday
is that garm is now an initiative of the
world economic Forum so the world
economic Forum which is the kind of
liberal James Bond villain group that
meets in Davos Switzerland up in the
Alps and decides how to rule the world
the world economic Forum gobbles up garm
as a flagship product under a flagship
project rather under the platform for
shaping the future of media
entertainment and Sport
you don't need to pull out your tinfoil
hat you don't need to go sussing around
the ponds to find the chemicals that
turn the frogs gay even though those
chemicals exist and Yale and the federal
government discovered them that's a
story for another time
all you need to notice all you need to
take away here is that the largest
corporations on Earth
have come together
to embrace far leftism including the
radical trans ideology they've agreed
not only to hold each other to those
standards they've now got so much weight
that they're pressuring the social media
companies to implement those standards
and it's it's being centralized even
further under banners of international
institutions like the world economic
forum
Bud Light as I've said from the
beginning can't totally disavow Dylan
Mulvaney can't disavow transgenderism
Bud light's corporate policies won't let
them do that but Bud Light also can
embrace transgenderism all that openly
because then they're going to lose their
entire customer base and then they're
not going to have a product to hold to
those standards anyway so they're caught
between a rock and a hard place right
now they're hoping that conservatives
just forget about it and they can move
on and continue to uphold these
standards and not change anything about
their corporate policies they're hoping
that conservatives will either have an
affection for the free market as some
kind of idol to say that we worship
corporations and they can do whatever
they want just just don't let the
government tell me what to do they're
betting on that and they're betting on
us having the attention span of a fruit
fly
so that we'll move on I think they're
surprised that conservatives continue to
boycott Bud Light that their their sales
continue to decline we've got to keep
that pressure up because it's about a
lot more than Bud Light you've got to
crack these
multi-national corporate corporate
policies
so that you get the pressure off of the
other companies you get the pressure off
of the social media companies you've got
you've got to keep pushing to crack the
whole thing if all we did was take down
transheiser bush
the machine would keep on turning man
that was one sizzling hot clip huh if
you want to get more of those clips and
long interviews and the yes or no game
and face off and The Daily Show you got
to subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel click it ring the bell
do the thing we'll catch you next time
[Music]